this is what the liberal regime
refers there is a video that just came
out unfortunately there was a hidden
camera in some restaurants some bar
of a an la health inspector la one of
the worst-run cities for coronavirus and
also they're not just
the worst run in terms of the spread of
the virus but they're also the worst run
in terms of
the psychos who are enforcing rules
there this
la health inspector shows up
shuts down this bar and then as she's
doing it
she does a little dance you can see it
through
the security footage
there she goes she's dancing around you
know
moving her hips shaking around
now i don't i don't want to read
too much into just this one video clip
it's pretty damning stuff
but maybe i don't know i don't know what
was going on in her head maybe she was
just maybe she's just a nut and she just
has to spontaneously start dancing in
public
if so you know not the best bedside
manner for a regulator who's
throwing people out of work but
i do know that normal is a choice
norms are a choice in many ways what
political correctness is what what
wokeness or you know whatever term you
want is is a new set of norms
actually i explore this topic in my
upcoming book which you can pre-order
right now speechless controlling words
controlling minds what
what political correctness does is
replaces the old moral norms
with new norms of speech so you're
replacing the standards and it's also
you're taking the focus from actions to
words
what what this woman did to go shut down
this business that was wrong of her to
do whether she danced or not
it's an arbitrary exercise of power it
should not be done right now
and i don't think any of us need to be
reminded
that woman gets her paycheck regardless
this woman goes in
shuts down a place of business
puts workers out of their job
probably puts the owner you know if this
goes on long enough out of
his job and she gets her paycheck and
she gets to dance on back down the
street
back to her office if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation historical
revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you